So, I live here in Boston,...
...and I am super passionate about digital media and publishing and new technologies.
And in terms of my own life, I am a novel seeker,...
...or I always look for the new thing.
I'm always up on current events and trends and almost like I'm a commitment-phobe,...
...but not like in a bad way, because I really want to commit to your company.
And you know, I love nothing more than to work hard,...
...but also go home and cook a really good meal,...
...because food is like a big part of my life.
Clearly, I could use some help.
Luckily, an expert wrote about this very topic and a question for hbr.org.
Joel Schwartzberg is a professional presentation coach.
So, I decided, why don't I talk to him directly and see what he could do.